roadkill Easy Bake Oven The Clash at
demon head and a store of unicorns from
Indie darling to Oscar winner to Marvel
Superhero Brie Larson's transformation
is stunning
Brie Larson born Brienne de celanes
expressed an interest in acting at age
six later moving to Los Angeles with her
mom after her parents got divorced
within a year she became the youngest
actor to enroll in the legendary
American Conservatory theater in San
Francisco where actors like Denzel
Washington and Winona Ryder cut their
teeth Larson attributes this early
ambition to her mother claiming that her
maternal grandparents quote wouldn't
allow her to have that kind of life
according to L magazine after adopting
the last name Larson from her
great-grandmother in an effort to appeal
to casting directors Brie began to
regularly book roles the first of those
was for a commercial parody on The
Tonight Show with Jay Leno in 1996
promoting Malibu mudslide Barbie
thankfully Larson was Charming enough as
a child actor to be invited back for
over a dozen more parodies like the
roadkill Easy Bake Oven she told Jimmy
Fallon in 2017. it's kind of where I
learned that I had comedic timing that
comedic timing would later come in handy
for Larson as she began to book more
roles on TV because coming to series
regular on raising Dad where she played
the daughter of Bob Saget's character
during the show's single season run in
2001.
while Larson was still far from becoming
an oscar-winning movie star her time in
the spotlight would come sooner than she
thought as her child acting career
slowly continued Larson eventually
recorded a song Invisible girl and
uploaded it to her website where a local
Los Angeles radio station picked it up
at age 15 Larson was offered a record
deal by Casablanca records giving her
the same shot at stardom as teens of the
time like Taylor Swift or Miley Cyrus
hey this is Brie Larson welcome to
sessions at AOL come on in Larson's
record label had her quickly record her
debut album finally out of PE which
after several delays was finally
released in Fall 2005. the album's lead
single she said was a minor hit on the
Billboard charts the album's 13th and
final track Hope Has Wings was featured
in Barbie and The Magic of Pegasus which
Larson promoted by performing on the
barbie float during the 2005 Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade although Larson
clearly had the potential to reach an
audience of angsty mid-2000s teens the
pop star life wasn't meant to be in
hindsight everything seems to have
worked out for the best with Larson
claiming in an interview with BuzzFeed
news in 2015 I was so insecure and so
hard on myself back then her musical
side wouldn't get sidelined for long
though
there was a lot writing on United States
of Terra a 2009 Showtime series set to
Star Tony Collette as a woman with
dissociative identity disorder Brie
auditioned to play Colette's character's
daughter Kate and the pilot allowing her
to potentially act alongside her
greatest acting hero but unfortunately
she didn't land the part that is until
the show is picked up and Kate was
recast giving Brie another shot at the
part which she eventually locked down
ironically this finally paired Brie with
the show's Creator Diablo Cody who had
penned Juno being a series regular on a
Showtime series for Three Seasons gave
Larson a lot of opportunities such as
the 2009 comedy film Tanner Hall and
even a role in our town for the
Williamstown theater Festival amongst
all these other projects however Larson
felt closest to Kate from United States
of Tara who is rebellious and selfish
towards her struggling mother although
critics had lots of praise for the show
particularly for the performances of
both Colette and Larson it was canceled
by Showtime after its third season in
2011. in an interview with BuzzFeed
Larson lamente the show's cancellation
and regrets not spending more time on
her character's bedroom set during their
final days of shooting saying I didn't
say my final goodbyes to those walls
after United States of Terra Larson's
jobs started to get more high profile in
2010 she co-starred Noah bombeck's
Greenberg alongside Ben Stiller and
Greta Gerwig which helped raise her
profile among independent film fans
however she made quite an impression on
mainstream audiences when she was cast
in Edgar Wright's 2010 film Scott
Pilgrim Vs the World adapted from the
graphic novel series if Larson had
struggled to grab the attention of
casting directors before that changed
with her Scott Pilgrim audition
according to Edgar Wright in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly Bree
who was 19 at the time maybe she was
even 18 when she auditioned blew
everybody else away that's certainly the
energy right wanted from the character
of Envy Adams the ex-girlfriend of
Michael Sarah Scott Pilgrim and lead
singer of the successful rock band The
Clash at demon head making good use of
Larson's experience as a musician even
though Scott Pilgrim Vs the World didn't
perform well at the box office its cult
following has kept her portrayal of Envy
Adams alive with vulture heralding The
Clash at demon head as one of the best
fake rock bands in cinematic case
history fortunately Larson will be
returning to the role with the rest of
the films cast for a Netflix animated
series proving that Larson's performance
is as Irreplaceable As It Gets
even though Larson could have easily
chased the Envy Adams Fame her career
naturally gravitated towards Independent
films following Scott Pilgrim Vs the
World Larson starred in the drama film
Rampart opposite Woody Harrelson this
time around the connection she felt to
her character like the one she had with
Kate from United States of Tara didn't
showcase Larson's best habits as an
actor as she told the Los Angeles Times
the consequence of playing the
emotionally intense role meant it took
her three times as long to get out of
that depression as it did to just do the
scenes it wasn't long before Larson
became an indie darling even with films
like an adaptation of Douglas light's
book The Trouble with bliss which
critics felt was a step down from the
source material around this time Larson
also dipped her toe into
responsibilities behind the camera in
2012 she co-wrote and co-directed the
short film the arm with Jesse Ennis and
Sarah Ramos which was awarded the
special jury prize at Sundance that year
it was becoming clear to the industry as
a whole that Larson was someone to keep
their eye on the comedic timing Larson
perfected on The Tonight Show with Jay
Leno didn't go to waste during these
Indie darling years either Larson played
a prominent role in the 2012 Studio
comedy 21 Jump Street based on the late
1980s TV show of the same name this time
around Larson's Talent didn't go
unnoticed with One reviewer for slate
writing Brie Larson is a find of major
proportions as Schmidt's goofy love
interest she also gets starred in a
couple of episodes of seasons 4 and 5 of
NBC's Community as Rachel a romantic
interest for Danny poody's TV obsessed
Abed however Bree's breakout role came
as a result of her dramatic Talent with
Dustin Daniel cretin's short-term 12 in
2013. after an audition over Skype
Larson was cast as Grace the supervisor
for a home of troubled teens who is also
dealing with her own unresolved trauma
the film contains many soon-to-be stars
of the late 2010s including Rami
malekith Stanfield and Caitlin Dever but
it speaks to Larson's powerful
performance that she's the standout of
the film short-term 12 quickly became
Larsen's most notable performance even
being nominated for an independent
Spirit award in 2014 a reviewer for the
telegraph correctly predicted Larson's
eventual success writing of her acting
in short-term 12 Larson in particular
gives a performance sweet sad and strong
that marks her out for a stellar career
however not even they could have
anticipated what would come next for
Larson
2015 became a turning point for Larson's
career in Hollywood as she became an
even more recognizable star in the Years
leading up to 2015 her profile began to
grow with minor appearances in films
like The Spectacular Now Don John and
The Gambler all of which continued to
earn her Acclaim as an up-and-coming
star still Larson was eager to showcase
the comedic timing she had been so proud
of learning years ago as a child actor
one of these efforts was digging for
fire a comedy starring Jake Johnson and
rosemary DeWitt as a couple who find
evidence of a dead body in their
backyard and rope and their close
friends to investigate the film notably
lacked a script it was shot over 15 days
based on a two-page outline written by
Johnson and director Joe Swanberg with
actors encouraged to improvise dialogue
and come up with their characters
backstories Larson's role as Max was
originally intended to have romantic
chemistry with Johnson's but Larson's
own contributions to the story nixed
that also in 2015 Larson starred in Amy
Schumer's train wreck as the lead
actress's sister while Schumer's
character struggles with commitment in
relationships Larson plays Devil's
Advocate as a happily married woman in
fact her husband in the film is played
by comedian Mike Birbiglia who also
starred alongside Larson in digging for
fire keeping her in the company of good
comedy while digging for fire was liked
by critics and train wreck was a box
office success Larson's other film in
2015 earned the actress her best reviews
yet that film was room directed by Lenny
Abramson and based on Emma donohue's
2010 book in the film Larson stars as
Joy a young woman who was held captive
for seven years bearing her captor's son
during that time played by Jacob
Tremblay like many of her previous roles
Larson committed fully to getting into
the mind of this incredibly traumatic
role with the help of a nutritionist
Larson adopted a strict diet to portray
joy and isolated herself in her own
apartment describing the production
process she told Vancouver City news it
took a lot to recoup at the end of the
day I needed a lot of sleep even though
this proved to be an exhausting Endeavor
for the actress it paid off in dividends
with critics raving about her and
tremblay's harrowing performances the
film was in Awards darling in the
2015-2016 season with Larson winning the
Academy Award for best actress at only
26 years old in her acceptance speech
she took the moment to thank audiences
for their acceptance of her stressing
the importance of movie fans in the film
industry for someone at the Pinnacle of
fully fledged movie stardom Larson
expressed a warm humility in this speech
room made Larson a household name
seemingly overnight as she also secured
a Golden Globe and bafta win for her
performance in the movie nevertheless
she was hesitant to accept a similar
role or be pigeonholed by playing a
traumatized mother instead opting to
embrace her Newfound status as an
international movie star in 2016 she
hosted Saturday Night Live Once Again
proving that even as an acclaimed
dramatic actress she possessed
unparalleled comedic Talent Larson
continued to embrace her potential as a
movie star following up room with the
2017 film Kong Skull Island in it she
plays Mason Weaver an investigative
photojournalist who joins the expedition
to find the legendary King Kong in an
attempt to expose the cruelty of humans
towards nature unlike previous King Kong
films Larson's character isn't defined
as the beautiful Damsel in Distress who
gets kidnapped by the giant ape in an
interview with Vanity Fair she said I
thought it was fun that I didn't have to
be this pristine creature some critics
considered this a step down for the
actress despite Larson's enthusiasm for
the film an article for the Washington
post about actresses struggles with
aging out of roles writes about Larson
one year you're winning an Oscar for an
emotionally demanding drama the next
year gasping your way through a great
big monkey movie but Larson would prove
them wrong by showing that she could be
a strong Blockbuster lead
shortly after Brie Larson skyrocketed
into success following room she was
introduced at San Diego Comic-Con in
2016 as the latest addition to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe Captain Marvel
herself
Brie Larson
[Applause]
Larson was set to Star as Carol Danvers
the very first female superhero to lead
her own solo film in the MCU with 2019's
Captain Marvel despite Larson's
eagerness to chase success the role was
not without its responsibilities she
said in an in-style interview that she
was attracted to the role due to
danver's strength explaining she's not
ever shrinking herself down the film was
also quite different from Marvel's
typical style at the time coming off the
heels of 2018's superhero tragedy
Avengers Infinity War Captain Marvel
turned back the clock to the mid-1990s
when Carol Danvers becomes the first
superhero contact of Samuel L Jackson's
Nick Fury and eventually a hero for the
refugee shapeshifters known as Scrolls
the role required Larson to adopt a
superhero Physique in real life
involving a nine month physical training
regimen thankfully Larson's effort paid
off with critics praising the film for
its originality amongst growing
superhero fatigue in the Marvel universe
according to one review for the New
Yorker that's all thanks to the film's
heroine stating praise be to Larson
finding us that Superhero films can be
Bringers of fun although the actress
Elsa faced sexist criticism from some
comic book fans the praise for her role
was probably enough to tune it out
Captain Marvel marked the third
on-screen collaboration between Larson
and Samuel L Jackson as the two had
previously starred together in 2017's
Kong Skull Island however long before
Captain Marvel was even shot Larson
recruited Jackson for her directorial
debut unicorn store which premiered at
the Toronto International Film Festival
in 2017 where it was bought by Netflix
and released on their streaming service
later in 2019 along with directorial
duties Larson also stars as kit and
artist who is offered by a mysterious
salesman to own a unicorn if she
accomplishes a certain number of
specific requirements Not only was the
role close to Larson's heart but it was
a project that had been a long time
coming prior to signing on as director
Larson auditioned for the film in 2012
but didn't land it when it came back
around following the successive room
with the option to direct it she took it
as her chance to show Hollywood her
untapped filmmaking skills unfortunately
critics were split on the final product
with some praising its earnestness and
depiction of femininity While others
criticized its lack of consistent tone
however some critics correctly noted
that Larson showed potential behind the
camera with screen daily writing Larson
navigates through a cute story's clear
limitations to deliver a film that's
often quite funny
Larson's career was on a steady incline
around the release of Captain Marvel
with the actress reprising her role in
2019's Avengers end game however
everything came to a halt in 2020 when
the covid-19 pandemic forced Hollywood
into shutdown it ended up giving Larson
a necessary break from acting having
turned 30 years old and noticing she was
being offered lots of roles reminiscent
of room she told Harper's Bazaar in 2023
I had all the same normal fears as
everybody else about being single and
being 30. Larson didn't spend the
pandemic in hiding however and chose
instead to remain closely connected to
her online fan base
hi I'm Brie Larson oh God hi this
resulted in her starting her own YouTube
channel where she posted workout Vlogs q
and A's and even tours of her Island in
perhaps the best quarantine video game
Animal Crossing New Horizons in 2021
Larson also started her own podcast with
Jesse Ennis learning Lots which featured
guests such as former co-stars like
Jacob Tremblay and Melissa McCarthy the
pandemic even led to her own fans
discovering Larson's musical Past after
the actress began posting guitar covers
on her social media Pages including the
one by Taylor Swift and even her own
former The Clash at demon head cut black
sheep in a time when Hollywood was stuck
in limbo Larson remained ever so
relevant online before finally making
her big screen return in 2023
off-screen Larson has been an advocate
for social change and women's rights
this has resulted in some pretty
controversial moments from the actress
including one instance when she opted
not to applaud Casey Affleck after
presenting him the Academy Award for
best actor in 2017 following sexual
assault allegations against him when
questioned about the action by Vanity
Fair she asserted I think that whatever
it was that I did on stage kind of spoke
for itself things got more heated for
Larson in 2019 when during press for
Captain Marvel she advocated for more
diversity among film critics and
journalists resulting in the review
bombing of her MCU debut the criticism
has continued to follow her to this day
despite efforts of review aggregate
Rotten Tomatoes to deter this type of
targeted trolling Larson has remained
vocal about what she believes in telling
Jane Fonda in an interview with
netaporte it doesn't feel right to be
quiet to this day Larson remains a
strong advocate for social justice she
was one of 300 women who organized the
time's up initiative to protest sexual
harassment in Hollywood and has been a
vocal supporter of issues like inclusion
transgender rights and law enforcement
accountability although her role in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has her
wearing colorful superhero outfits it's
her activism that's really heroic
2023 is a big year for Larson especially
with her role as Captain Marvel she last
portrayed the character in the
mid-credits scene of 2021's Xiang Chi
and the legend of the ten Rings directed
by her former short-term 12 and just
Mercy collaborator Dustin Daniel
she also made a cameo in a post-credits
scene at the end of the Disney plus
series Ms Marvel teasing her story in
the upcoming 2023 MCU film the Marvels
most recently Larson entered the Fast
and Furious franchise in fast X joining
an ensemble cast that includes Vin
Diesel Jason Momoa and Michelle
Rodriguez fast X is a relatively small
role for Larson compared to the Marvels
which finds Carol Danvers taking the
lead for the first time since 2019's
Captain Marvel although this time she
won't be alone the Marvels will team up
Larson's Danvers with two other MCU
heroines Iman vilani's Captain Marvel
superfan Kamala Khan from Ms Marvel as
well as Monica Rambo from 2021's wand
division portrayed by Tiana Paris the
film finds the trio of hero shopping
places every time they use their powers
which made tie back to Carol's past with
the cree it's one of the most highly
anticipated films of 2023 which likely
comes as a surprise to Larson how long
will you play Captain Marvel for I don't
know
I don't know does anyone want me to do
it again the short answer yes they do
foreign